organisé par l'association force des
mixités la dictée pour tous invité
samedi dernier parents et enfants à
venir s'adonner à l'exercice difficile
de la dictée un moyen de lutter contre
l'illettrisme et l'inégalité des chances
en réunissant les gens autour du
patrimoine linguistique français c'est
la première fois que je fais ça depuis
que j'ai quitté l'école en 1975 et puis
way pour voir mon niveau c'est un moyen
je dirais pédagogique et surtout ludique
d'apprendre à nos enfants les valeurs
très simple déjà d'une part notre
patrimoine parce que là vous allez voir
le la thématique sévère sur l'assemblée
nationale mais surtout c'est de mettre
en avant très simplement la la richesse
de notre langue l'événement de la dictée
pour tous c'est intergénérationnel c'est
de revenir tous les publics de toutes
origines de toutes horizons de toutes
classes sociales et se retrouver autour
de notre patrimoine linguistique c'est
un gros problème qu'on voit dans les
mails on voit dans dans l'est
dans les rapports ou dans n'importe quel
document pas mal de fautes d'orthographe
une action encouragé par des
personnalités de tous les domaines après
gad elmaleh au château de versailles en
2019 c'est l'acteur et réalisateur steve
tran qui a accepté d'être lecteurs sur
cette dictée nos jeunes c'est notre
futur est il important aujourd'hui de
remettre
remettre tout ça en entre parce que
c'est vrai quand tu vas sur twitter
facebook et sur les réseaux sociaux il
est vrai qu'au niveau grammaire
orthographe ça fait un peu flipper tu
vois moi j'ai peur j'ai des gamins je me
dis ouais j'espère que vont pas écrire
comme ça je trouve ça très important on
essaie de populariser démocratiser la
dictée et pour la rendre plus fun plus
cool surtout à travers les nouvelles
générations c'est grâce aux
personnalités l'effort a laissé place au
réconfort en fin de journée avec une
distribution de livres une remise de
prix et de l'eau et une séance de
dédicaces